okay Michelle you have been with the
franchise since the beginning so who
would better know quotes from this
franchise than you so we're going to
test your knowledge Oh should I be
worried you're not being worried we'll
find out ready the most important thing
in life will always be the people in
this room right here right now
Vin Diesel Fast Five Dom Toretto there
should be like a belt men you got to
check that emotion your voice just went
from shaggy to scooby-doo ah we do Roo
Roo that would be Chris making a remark
to Ty would you believe I knocked him
out with my charm
ah that was me in Fast and Furious 6 I
believe it was seven because there's a
fight with uh with Rosie they're all one
movie to me by the way are they really
yes it's like one long movie I don't I
don't break it up we find them we take
them as a team and we bring them back
and above all else we don't ever ever
let them get into cars I would say Fast
& Furious 6 fine and a manicure I'm
horrible at this trivia stuff I was
doing I was doing okay why are they
shooting at me I don't know maybe
because you're in an orange Lamborghini
although that's obvious I mean that's
the last one we did past eight eight of
the period and that's Tyrese you got it
he was Tyrese and and yeah yeah there
you go
you got that one Michelle
Fandango thank you for playing along
this is so guys go see the fate of the
Furious and where can they get their
tickets and mango
[Music]
you
[Music]